our next guest stars in the fourth and
final season of the Emmy winning dark
comedy Barry her name is Sarah Goldberg
she earned an Emmy nomination for the
role of an ambitious actor named Sally
Reed on the show in this season Sally
Goes On The Run with her boyfriend Barry
a Hitman turned aspiring actor himself
after he escapes from prison in the
series The Story fast forwards eight
years with a newly religious Barry and
Sally who are raising a young son and
they argue over Barry's plan to return
to LA to kill again this time their
former acting teacher Gene take a look
you know
you know I don't think that this is
God's message for you
this goes against everything we believe
killing is a sin a big one
and I don't think that's a little
discussion all right we either do this
or drop John off at an orphanage and we
kill ourselves
just want to do this because Gene turned
you in I want her son to know his
parents he thinks my name is Emily but
he knows the real you
[Music]
so nice to meet you guys all right so
your character is Sally but Sally's now
living as Emily and her life has taken a
very dark turn I was reading that when
you uh auditioned for this role had
season one Bill Hader called you and
said how would you like if this becomes
a multi-season series which it has how
would you like your character to
progress and you said let's go dark I
said let's go dark I said I want to go
the full way Gina Roland's opening night
woman under the influence him and he
held true to his promise why why were
you why were you so excited to take on
that challenge I just think the tone of
this show is so elastic and it's wild
you know like we signed up for a comedy
and since then I feel like we've run
through every genre from horror to
Thriller to drama and I just wanted to
see how far we could take it well you've
taken it pretty far can we just give a
shout out to you what TV line says about
you Ms Goldberg
Sarah Goldberg has been wowing us for
Four Seasons now with her work but this
week she topped herself by essentially
crafting a performance within a
performance as Sally that's so kind I
need to send that person some cake
that's so great because you did you did
Sarah you started out as a little girl
neck as as a girl next door but she's so
freaking complicated that's right well
they sort of Trojan Horse this character
where when I read the original pilot
script what I thought was so clever was
she sort of presents as this girl next
door girlfriend character but actually
she is this really dark complex
character and even in the pilot there
was that pivot in that twist and I
thought that made the script really
stand out and you know she's an unusual
female character and I wanted that kind
of challenge are you ready for it to end
because you're the only one in the room
that's seen the finale right and this is
what's so fascinating to me about it is
that two episodes left I can't figure
out how this is going to end are you
satisfied with the finale are you ready
I was I was I was quite emotional
watching the ending I was very emotional
watching all of our castmates rap you
know it's been seven years since we
started this show and so it's been a
full life cycle and I think we're really
going to miss going to work together but
it's time the story wraps up where it
should so and where it should is it
happily ever after
what do you think
um earlier you use the word elastic to
describe the show you can also use that
word to describe the definition of Love
Story would you say this isn't
necessarily a love story no I've never
felt that there was a love story between
Barry and Sally their relationship you
didn't no oh I did it's oh good okay
there lies the complications yeah yeah
but good yeah yeah I just felt like now
you know here's two people who are so
myopic in their needs that they really
project onto each other and they never
really see each other and then
ironically later when they're on the run
it's like the most honest their
relationship ever gets but they're in
this like survival based kind of mess
and so yeah it's always sort of been I
feel like they've used each other over
the years yeah what are you excited
about next
um well you're getting rave reviews Ms
gold over
yeah I'm working on a show called
industry actually in the UK yes yeah I'm
going to do their season three so I got
to learn to say things about Finance
really quickly that I don't understand
so you're still loving your job you're
still liking what you do I I feel so
lucky to do what I do you know I get to
play make-believe for a living and put
on costumes and do what we did as kids
you know so I feel really lucky to get
to do what I do no I was thinking about
when you first started the role because
were you working and you get the call
Bill Hader wants to do X Y and Z what
were you doing
um well seven years ago I was very much
unemployed I think I was in my bathrobe
eating banana and peanut butter and
toast and my amazing manager Peter kusak
has called me and was like Bill Hader
has this new HBO pilot and I think it's
your part and I was like okay cool yeah
let's do that one then I'm available I
think I'm available I'll check my diary
so you know and then I went through
quite a lengthy audition process but I
just I really felt understood Sally you
know and yeah I I've always felt that
with her she's a complicated character
and I always said you know you don't
have to like her you just have to know
her
yeah well the show of success is not
complicated it's a hit so thank you very
much thank you bravo bravo the fourth
and final season of Barry airs Sunday
nights on HBO and HBO Max